[Musique]
françoise dorléac et catherine deneuve
censeurs dans la vie elles sont jumelles
dans le film que tourne jacques demy qui
s'appelle les demoiselles de rochefort
bon on peut swing ce en place alosi
moteur
les bacs être heureux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
djabi chanter leur santé des plantes et
le jour chanter la nuit polaire et
moteurs
[Musique]
essayez a disparu et lui quand le pense
en est allé est allé du côté des saisons
mans
on ne peut que soupirer
b mais pour revenir un jour d'été
lorsque l'hiver s'est installé
et que vous tracasser glace et il faut
aimer
jacques demy les demoiselles ou un
caractère évidemment très différent
solange un caractère moderne ya qu au
fond d'elle-même dans ce qu'elle soit
très romantique et delphine qui n
apparaissent romantique ça et finalement
plus modernes suivant leur caractère et
suivant la révolution
elles ont de toute façon le même
problème toutes les deux sont à l'arrêt
faire de l'amour
nous sommes déçus mais pas seulement
rémy passage ça sonnerait dont toutes
nos dames
ayant fui les alentours ils fassent pas
là
toledo nous émeut tout nommé ne vais pas
maman danielle darrieux ses prix bas
travail à paris yann
dogou les deux frères deux érudits
et pour cela vendre
de sa vie des frises françoise rêve de
jouer la dame aux camélias et catherine
rôles comme arriver salonsce des
françoises et delphine cd4 et
bathymétriques suis la reine
oui un petit que je me fasse la vente a
vu ce que je me permets catherine
deneuve fabrice abriel rencontre tombe
dans le team françoise dorléac luc
savard finale et que je vois quand même
j'espère et qui j'avais dit je le sers
conseil roche
non mais je crois qu'ils allaient voyez
maintenant j'ai épousé ma maison par
aqmi
en tous les cas d'un seul coup tu as une
protestante en visant jean marc simon
drac du fermage l'agencé plus petit café
madsen tranquillement kg de moules pour
tous
vous avez maintenant ils sont tous fans
allemands il a fait de drôles bon c'est
pas vrai en langage c'est sûr que vous
visez droit
oui ouistes et itinéraires non c'est une
erreur petit miroir dis moi si j'ai
vraiment la plus laide lui c'était ça
venait est comme ça une 16,2 d'instinct
de jeu d'enfant
[Musique]
pas encore
la rochelle fanion on me dit où va ma
route qu'elle soit timide et très
complexée qu'elle ne se connaissent pas
du tout ne sache pas comment s'habiller
qu'elle sache jamais comment se tenir
elle ne sait pas quoi faire de ses bras
tout ça c'est vrai mais elle est
tellement comédienne hélène tellement
joué et finalement elle va passer par
dessus sa timidité par dessus ses
compétiteurs tartare jabiim du manger un
steak obligera pas tournage mais nous
avons déjà perdu un gros plan
aujourd'hui
ok chéri
peut-être bien sympathique mais une
chose qui fait quelques très belles
c'est qu'elles soient d'ordre et déjeuné
ou dîné avec elle c'est un régal
c'est un festival de vacheries gentil
lequel se lance comme ça avait été un
jeu entre elles depuis surnom de
l'enfance laquelle est la doublure de
l'os
ma soeur a tapoté il donc de plus en
plus de ce qu'est ce qui s'passe leur
espace moi je me risque pas d'arriver au
bourget voilà en france où les diggers
salon vienne - la bosnie pour
l'embrasser devant le mauvais sillage il
faut aller allons-y allons-y pour le
faire ça il est bien au point est très
bien car de catherine
bon après on peut quatre moteurs
franchement pourtant essentielle les
bacs sourire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
à
et la vie au secteur santé moselis la
santé le jour où santé la nuit ça fait
parler
la rue
[Musique]
31e sans permis
j
en vérité le chanteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est bien
je viens
[Musique]